we have been seeing slightly more
journalistic rigor when it comes to how
the White House press corps has been
dealing with press secretary Sarah
Huckabee Sanders over the last maybe
three to four weeks one example of this
we talked about a couple of weeks ago
which was CNN deciding to live
fact-check Sarah Huckabee Sanders during
her press briefing so as she started
telling lies facts would come up on
screen in text form on CNN during a
recent White House press briefing that
was a really great thing we applauded
that and that that's exactly what media
outlets should be doing but I've also
insisted that the press corps really
should be doing much more and that the
press corps needs to step it up when
they are in the room with Sarah Huckabee
Sanders including when she doesn't
answer a question and moves on to the
next reporter the next reporter to be
called on instead of asking their
question should insist hey hold on a
second Sarah you didn't answer that last
question I have the same question let's
see if you can answer it now that it's
been asked a second time call her out
make her either answer the question or
cut the press conference short which is
probably what she would do we are now
seeing basically the approach of doing
both of those things from Sarah Huckabee
Sanders a couple of days ago
Sarah Huckabee Sanders showed up to the
White House press briefing room an hour
late without any explanation constantly
cut off answers and kept talking about
being short on time and then cut the
entire thing short after about five
minutes and fortunately some of the
reporters in the room called her out and
said Sarah why don't you do your job I'm
gonna play a little bit of audio and
video for you here listen for someone in
the room who goes oh when another
reporter says Sarah do your job this is
what press briefings have become in this
administration I encourage you guys are
tuned into the president's event we'll
talk to you soon
it was a 10-minute briefing do your job
Sarah what an absolute and utter
embarrassment she was asked about
Trump's charity being forced to shut
down over rampant criminality she was
asked about Donald Trump's threat to
shut down the government that he issued
when he was at the Oval Office at that
wacky meeting with Democratic leadership
Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer she
dodged answering every single question
and then left after somewhere between
five and ten minutes why even bother
doing this Pat right I mean it would
almost attract less attention to stop
doing the briefings altogether than to
do them in this way well I think Sarah
Huckabee Sanders has one foot out the
door
remember that report from the beginning
of the year saying that Sarah would be
leaving the administration come around
this time I think that's what's going on
I think she's ready to go the press she
may be going and the press briefings
actually may stop altogether NPR has an
interesting article which points out
that if you look at the frequency of
these briefings and the duration of the
briefings both are declining and I was
reminded of that movie from the 90s with
Will Smith Independence Day where
there's a signal coming from the alien
spacecraft which is dwindling and they
can calculate that if it continues at
this pace the signal will end altogether
and at that point of course the aliens
will attack it's sort of the same thing
if you follow the signal of duration
shrinking and frequency being reduced by
sarah huckabee sanders for her press
briefings the press briefing will
disappear in something like six months
the press briefing for the time being is
down to something like every couple of
weeks five to ten minutes because
there's really no way to spend more than
five or ten minutes in front of the
press corps without being exposed for
the totally embarrassing actions of the
president that she is trying to cover up
and explain every single day amazing
time to live amazing time to be living
through and III just can't even imagine
what we're going to see in 2019 send me
your thoughts should they just stop the
press briefings altogether I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show one of
today's sponsors is privacy comm slash
Pakman this is a free service that I've
actually been using myself for a while
now and I love it you just take a few
seconds to link your debit card or bank
account to privacy coms mobile app or
browser extension for Firefox and Chrome
and what that does is allow you to
instantly create virtual credit cards
that are linked to your bank account so
that you're not actually putting your
real debit card number on the Internet
and you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5 towards your first purchase when
you sign up using that link below